Welcome to toxic Hugo.
I'm mark and I'm here with Paul Smith,
who's a best selling author of a few bucks.
In fact,
lead with a story is one that I read recently and it was a very popular,
also parenting with a story.
I haven't read that yet,
but I have kids,
so I plan to read it.
Same.
Paul spent a couple of years as a consultant at Accenture and 20 years at
Procter and gamble as a director of consumer communications research.
He's a popular keynote speaker.
He's been featured in the Wall Street Journal,
Inc Magazine Times,
Forbes,
success magazine,
a lot of big publications.
So Paul,
thanks a lot for joining us.
Very welcome.
It's good to be here.
Yeah.
Great.
So tell us a little bit about this book sell with a story that you just wrote.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I will,
as you can tell,
it's kind of the,
the third in a series.
And I guess I didn't really know when I started,
I was going to write a trilogy,
I guess it is,
but it kind of worked out that way.
Um,
but,
but they're all about how to use storytelling to make you more effective at
whatever it is that,
that you're doing.
So the first one obviously is to help you be a better leader.
The second one to be a more effective parent.
And this one obviously to be more effective at selling.
And,
and that is not just if you're selling a thing,
a product,
a or it could be a service or it could just be your ideas.
A lot of us,
a lot of them are trafficking,
trafficking in ideas.
So even if that's just making a presentation to your boss or we're making a
recommendation around the office,
that kind of thing.
Uh,
so it's,
it's t to use storytelling to help you be more effective.
Yeah.
Great.
Well,
I can definitely use that.
I'm in sales,
so I've read the book and I found some Nice tidbits there.
Good,
good.
Um,
what exactly is storytelling for business?
So tell us more about how a salesperson can use storytelling.
Yeah.
Well,
so I,
I,
I think that word storytelling has been used,
um,
a lot lately.
And for things that it probably was never intended to be used for,
you know,
a 15 or 20 years ago when somebody were to say a story,
you would know exactly what they meant.
But,
but these days I think people use it for different things.
Ya know,
nowadays you'll hear people say,
oh,
our,
our marketing plans a story or are,
you know,
our,
our new copy on air,
it tells a story or a mission statement tells a story or a brand logo is a
story.
And,
and,
uh,
if people can get some extra meaning in their work by calling those things
stories,
then that's great.
But,
um,
but they're probably not really stories.
Uh,
there is a difference.
You know,
not every set of words that has meaning a is a story.
Just like not every set of words,
uh,
that's,
that's entertaining is a poem.
I mean,
their,
their story is something different.
So when I say storytelling,
I actually mean telling a story about something that happened to somebody.
I don't just mean making a compelling speech or writing a great memo.
Um,
you know,
uh,
in fact,
imagine a,
so you're in sales,
so imagine it's next week.
Uh,
you're,
you're sitting down on a meeting to prepare for a sales call that you've got
coming up,
uh,
with a new perspective client.
And the boss comes in to the meeting,
started and says,
okay,
let's get this meeting started.
What's our story?
You know,
do you think for a minute that what that person means is his story in the
traditional sense?
Probably not.
But what they probably mean is what's the logical series of facts and data and
arguments that we're going to put together probably in a PowerPoint presentation
that we're going to essentially read to the client or the prospect such that by
the end of the meeting,
we have the best odds of success at selling something.
That's what they mean by a story.
And that's,
that's great.
Uh,
because you need that when you're going into a sales call.
But we wouldn't have called that 20 years ago a story we would have called that
a sales pitch or presentation slides or a message track or talking points or
something.
So I'm not talking about talking points or message tracks were sales pitches.
I'm talking about actual stories.
In fact,
it might help if I gave you an example.
Right?
Yeah.
So,
um,
so last year,
and this was the one that actually happened to me personally,
so last summer my wife and I were at a,
um,
uh,
an art fair and she was looking for,
a piece of art for our son's bathroom at home.
And so we get,
we're going booth to booth and we get to this booth of this one artist,
he's an underwater photographer,
his name is Chris Goog and he just does these mesmerizing underwater shots of
sea anemones and sea turtles and coral reefs and stuff like that.
And uh,
she gets attached to this one picture that to me looked about as out of place as
a pig in the ocean,
right?
Because it was literally a pig in the ocean picture of a pig in the ocean.
And I just thought that was the craziest thing.
And eventually I got my turn to ask a question of the the photographer and I
said,
dude,
once with the pig and the ocean,
right.
And that is when the magic started.
I mean,
he said,
Oh yeah,
it was the craziest thing.
He said,
that picture was taken in The Bahamas off the coast of this uninhabited island
called big major cay.
Instead.
Apparently what happened was a few years ago,
a local entrepreneur decided to raise a pig farm for Bacon,
I guess.
And so he goes and buys this whole drove of pigs and he puts them out on this
island where you can keep them for free.
And he said any points of the picture and goes,
but look up there behind the pig on the beach.
And he said,
right behind the beach,
what kind of vegetation do you see up there?
And I looked and I kind of squinted and I said,
well,
the only thing I recognize or Cactus,
and he said,
yeah,
that's a problem.
Pigs don't like cactus is that these poor pigs weren't thriving.
They couldn't eat.
It's hard to eat a cactus.
Right?
And,
uh,
fortunately for them,
they quickly noticed that a local restaurant owner on a neighboring island was
boating his kitchen refuse every night over the big major cay and dumping it a
few dozen yards off shore.
So pretty soon these hungry little pigs smell the food and they,
they're hungry enough that they are,
they brave the ocean waters and eventually figured out how to get out there and
get the food first one pig then to announce two or three generations later and
all the pigs on big major cay can swim.
So,
and he said,
in fact,
now that nobody even calls it big major cay anymore,
everybody calls it pig island,
right?
So if you,
for those of you that have heard of it,
if you ever go to the Caribbean and go check out pig island and then these,
there are these pigs and they swim.
And he said,
in fact,
I didn't even have to get out of my boat.
Like normally I have to put on all this scuba gear and wet suit and stuff and it
takes hours to get my pictures.
He said when I got two big major cay,
I just leaned over and stuck my camera out of the water because the pigs swim
right up to the boat.
Yeah.
Cause they think they're going to get fed,
right.
They've learned that boat's mean food.
Right.
All right.
So anyway,
I'm of course at that point I've got my credit card out and I'm like,
we'll take it.
Right.
Totally sold that picture.
And you know,
of course it did,
right?
I mean,
two minutes earlier,
that picture was worth nothing to me.
But after hearing that Short two minute story,
I was like,
I gotta have this.
Right.
And why?
Because now I wasn't just buying a picture.
I was buying a story and it's a story I get to tell everybody that comes into my
house.
And uh,
and it's,
it's also,
it's a,
it's an animal psychology lesson,
a history lesson,
a geography lesson,
all kind of rolled into one.
Right.
It's just an interesting story.
So that's when I say sales story,
that's what I mean.
I don't mean Paul here.
The three reasons why you got to buy this picture.
It is the right size for your bathroom,
it's the right color Palette for your no towels.
You know what?
And it's priced just right.
I mean that's a satisfaction logic and emotion and uh,
yeah,
purchasing decision I imagine,
right?
Yeah.
Most sales pitches are very logical and quite frankly,
their list.
It's a list of the reasons why you should buy this.
Can,
I'm not talking about sales lists,
sales stories are something very different like that.
And that,
by the way,
that's just one type of story.
I mean there's,
there's 20 some odd types of sales stories that I talk about in the book.
That particular one is what I call a value adding story.
It's a story that makes the thing that you're selling more valuable,
right?
But there are lots of other kinds as well.
So how would a sales person come up with stories like this?
Yeah,
yeah.
So first of all,
be observant,
right?
I mean,
you know,
that's,
that thing actually happened to me at that art fair and it made an impression on
me,
so I remembered it.
Right?
So the first thing you've got to do is to recognize that what you need as a
salesperson is a repertoire of stories to tell.
So when you see a story happen or hear a great story,
don't just enjoy it and let it pass through your brain.
Recognize that's something important.
Like if it moved you in some way,
it will move other people when you tell them.
So collected just like you would
just like you would a f a fact or an interesting argument or a good piece of
analysis or super compelling piece of data.
Like if you heard that during your workday,
oh I'm gonna write that down,
I'm going to,
I need that.
I you should be thinking of that way about stories as well,
but,
but you can be more intentional about it too.
I'm not like I recommend people,
you know,
in,
in the back of the book is the list of here are the 25 types of sales stories
that you,
you probably need go find them.
Like intentionally go on a story hunt,
you know,
and it might take you six months to do it to find all the right ones,
but ask other people,
you know,
to tell people,
here are the stories I'm looking for.
Just like you would do if you were to tell your colleagues,
Hey I need data on this or I'm looking for this type of analysis.
Right.
Is anybody had this type of experience?
Do the same things with your stories.
I'm looking for this kind of a story and eventually you'll get your list of 25
filled out and you'll,
you'll be in a better position.
Or do you recommend using a story every
time you have a sales meeting?
Well probably,
but I should,
I should clarify.
The type of storytelling I'm talking about is not just to be used during the
sales pitch.
Random.
I mean the sales and the people that I interviewed for the book and I
interviewed people at 50 or 60 different companies around the world,
professional salespeople and professional buyers by the way,
professional procurement people.
Cause I figure who better to tell you what sales stories work and which ones
don't.
Then the buyers.
Right.
In fact,
I'm convinced now that I learned more from the buyers and sellers.
Tell me a little bit about how you did all those interviews.
You just contacted buyers all over the place where these people you knew from
your former days at Procter and gamble or,
yeah,
some of them.
So I mean I,
I started of course with people that I knew,
but the,
the last question I typically ask in any of my interviews is now that you know
what I'm looking for,
who do you think I should talk to?
And that of course it turns out,
oh,
Bob and accounting or Jane and sales or you know,
Sally the procurement,
you've got to talk to her.
You know,
so the,
I ended up getting more my interviews that way.
Um,
but yeah,
so the,
the,
the process,
the research,
of course,
I,
I typically read all the other books that have been written on the,
on the topic or as many as I can,
I can get through.
But most of it is these,
these primary interviews that I do with these people all over the world.
Um,
and I ended up reverse engineering my way into what makes for a compelling
story.
But,
um,
one of the questions I was asking them to kind of get back to the other question
is,
when are you using storytelling in the sales process?
And the,
and of course I found out what their sales process is and it turns out
everybody's got different names for their parts of the sales process.
You could probably articulate right now what your sales process is and do.
The names that you use for those parts would be different than people at other
companies would use.
But they're all pretty similar.
And I mean,
and it starts from as early as identifying who your prospect is that you want to
sell to,
to building rapport with the buyer,
to making the actual sales pitch itself,
to resolving objections,
to negotiating price,
to closing the sale to service after the sale.
I mean,
that probably sounds familiar to you,
right?
Yeah.
So,
so that's kind of storytelling I'm talking about happens in all of those parts,
not just the main sales pitch.
So,
so the,
the best salespeople that I,
that I interviewed were starting their storytelling the minute they met somebody
and it would be a story to help introduce themselves to help the prospect
understand who I am,
what I'm about,
what it is that I do for living.
Then there's the rapport building,
then the actual sales pitch itself.
And yes,
there should be two or three stories out of a,
I don't know,
30 minutes sales call,
seven or eight minutes of that probably ought to be in storytelling.
And the other 23 minutes could be normal sales pitch type stuff.
But then I found great salespeople actually using storytelling to negotiate
price to resolve objections and a really creative way and actually closing the
sale by,
by creating more of a sense of urgency and,
and some really creative uses of storytelling after the sale was made to build
loyalty and get people to,
to be happy with the purchase decision they've made.
And now that I'm doing business with you,
you want me to stay happy,
right?
And storytelling can help there too.
So I was really just surprised,
pleasantly surprised at all the uses of storytelling throughout the entire sales
process.
And why is storytelling so powerful?
Why does that convince somebody to buy when they wouldn't have otherwise?
Yeah.
So there,
there are a lot of reasons.
Um,
my top few I would tell you is first of all,
it turns out that human beings don't make decisions as logically and rationally
as we think we do.
Right?
We like to think we're these logical,
rational thinking machines.
But,
um,
the truth is in that cognitive science has been done,
tells us this,
that human beings make subconscious emotional,
sometimes irrational decisions in one place in their brain.
And then they justify that logically and rationally in a different place in the
brain after the fact.
But that's the conscious part that we remember.
So that's why we think that we're so rational.
But the truth is our decisions were,
were made,
you know,
three tenths of a second earlier in the subconscious part.
Facts and logic and data only talk to that conscious,
logical,
rational part of the brain.
They don't talk to the subconscious,
you know,
a emotional part of the brain stories.
Do you need both?
Yeah.
So,
and I'm definitely not an advocate of abandoning your logical rational sales
pitch for a story that would be foolish not to.
Um,
I recommend this as something in addition to,
so out of a 30 minute sales call,
instead of having 30 minutes of sales pitch,
you know,
the traditional logic only sales pitch,
you ought to have two or three stories in there to speak to both parts of the
brain.
I think you'd be more effective that way.
Was there a point in your career when this topic really became more important
for you and you decided,
hey,
I'm going to write a book on this lead with a story,
for example?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I was probably 15 years into my career when it,
I guess it finally dawned on me that storytelling is important.
I mean,
you know,
they didn't teach me that in business school.
Uh,
nobody told me that when I joined P and g or joined Arthur Anderson,
uh,
you know,
I just,
I've just finally dawned on me that the leaders that I admired the most and
wanted to work for or be like when I grew up in the company,
um,
we're great storytellers.
And so once I realize that,
then I,
I set out trying to learn how to do it.
And it was,
it was kind of hard because there's not a lot of classes.
You can't just go up to the local community college and take a class on
storytelling.
There are,
at least in most places you can.
And if you do,
it's certainly not in the business school,
right?
It's in the creative arts department.
Or I could,
you know,
but I don't want to learn to be a,
uh,
a fiction novelist.
I mean,
that's not the kind of storytelling that I was interested in learning.
I was interested in learning the two minute type of story,
you know?
But that was nonfiction,
real stories.
And so that's when I set out interviewing CEOs and leaders all over the world,
just on my own personal learning journey.
And that just ended up turning into a book.
I,
I guess I finally decided,
gosh,
if I want to know this this badly,
probably other people do as well.
And so it became a book idea as well.
Okay.
And so you wrote this book while you were working at Procter and gamble.
What was the point where you decided,
hey,
this is a popular book.
Maybe I should go out and do this full time?
Oh yeah.
Well,
so it kind of wasn't in that order.
I,
I didn't know for sure that I was going to leave,
make a career of it,
but I,
I did get fortunate and it,
uh,
it's allowed me to do that.
But yeah,
there was this,
there was one moment where I really had to make a decision.
Right?
Do I do,
I keep working at my day job and I was 45 or 46 years old at the time,
so too young for retirement and you know,
I got kids to get through college and all that stuff.
So it was a really tough decision.
And,
um,
and I actually ended up asking my father for advice,
you know,
he's 80 years old at the time and I figured you're never too old to learn from
somebody older and miser.
Um,
and,
and he's a hard of hearing,
so I,
I can't call him on the phone anymore.
So I literally write him a letter and,
and uh,
he,
he writes back and I thought he was just going to give me advice.
Oh,
absolutely.
It's on,
you should go pursue your dream or he was going to tell me,
are you not surprised?
I mean,
stick it out for five more years and retire and then go play around with the
stuff.
And,
but he didn't do either of those things.
He,
he literally,
I ironically told me a story about himself that I had never heard before and
that none of my siblings had ever heard either.
And he said,
he said,
when I was five years old,
I knew exactly what I wanted to do with my life.
He said I wanted to be a singer,
you know,
like a Frank Sinatra,
Tony Bennett.
I mean,
he's 80,
that's his genre,
right?
And,
uh,
he said,
and I knew that the first day of kindergarten,
um,
you know,
I get there and the teacher asks if any of us have any special talent,
like dancing or magic tricks or whatever.
And he said,
I raised my hand and I said,
I can sing despite the fact that he'd never sung in front of anybody but his mom
in the kitchen.
Right.
And so of course,
what do you think she,
she does when he says that?
Oh,
of course,
Bobby,
stand up and sing us a song.
So little five year old,
Bobby stands up and he says,
I belt it out.
My favorite song right there acappella in front of everybody.
And he said,
I nailed it.
I got all the words right in the melody and everything,
and it was so proud.
And he said in the teacher,
and the other students stood up and they applauded me like my first standing
ovation my first time to ever sing a song.
And he said,
that's the moment that I knew that this is what I was destined to do with my
life.
And he said,
unfortunately,
that turned out not just to be the first time in my life that I ever sang in
front of an audience.
It turned out to be the last time I ever sang in front of an audience.
And he said,
the truth is,
son.
Um,
it wasn't just that life got in the way.
I just,
I never had the courage to pursue it.
And he said,
that was 75 years ago,
and there's not a month that goes by that I don't regret that decision.
He said,
someday you're going to wake up,
you're going to be 80 years old like me.
It's gonna be too late for you to pursue your dream.
You know?
And,
and if that wasn't enough,
and it was,
by the way,
I thought it wasn't enough,
I kid you not,
he,
he closed the,
the letter with these words.
He said,
I'd love to see you achieve your dream,
but that doesn't mean in your lifetime,
son,
that means in mine.
And I mean,
you know,
Tick Tock,
right?
I mean these guys 80.
So yeah.
So literally two days later I walked into my boss's office,
Kirk Perry at Google walked into my boss's office and I resigned from my 20 year
career to pursue this dream.
And it's absolutely been the best decision ever made.
And I,
I probably would have made that decision eventually,
but I wouldn't have made it on that day or that week or that month if it were
not for that story from my dad.
And you mentioned that that story also inspired your boss.
I think it did.
You'll probably,
you need to have him on here and,
and have that conversation as well.
But uh,
yeah,
you,
you may not have,
uh,
have had the pleasure of him working here quite as soon.
Maybe if it wasn't for that.
But we'll see.
Yeah.
You've interviewed people all over the world as you mentioned.
Are there cultures or types of people that are better storytellers than others
naturally made?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so two parts of that.
First of all,
definitely there are cultural differences in storytelling.
And in some places people just do it a lot more.
And I think of,
uh,
in Latin America,
there's a lot more storytelling that just happens culturally then in eastern
Europe and a or maybe an in western Europe and in Germany for example.
Um,
uh,
so,
so there are definitely places where it's more accepted and expected as part of,
uh,
even in business interactions.
But there's also definitely people who are naturally gifted storytellers and
some people who are not.
And one of the things I learned as,
as I interviewed these people all over the world,
I obviously I learned that.
But what I also learned is that if you're not one of those people who's
naturally good at it,
you can still learn it.
And that's in fact,
one of the misconceptions that I've found a lot of people have is they think
that some people are just born a natural storyteller or not.
And if they're not,
they'll just never be.
Uh,
and I find it to be like,
um,
uh,
like art or music.
Like some people are natural born musicians or artists.
And by the way,
I'm neither of those things.
But I bet if I wanted to learn to play the guitar,
if I took lessons for six months,
I could probably learn.
Now I'm never going to be fabulous,
but I could,
I could probably stretch them out a few songs,
right?
But with storytelling people just,
but,
and most people know that they,
most people know if I want really wanted to be an artist or musician,
I could learn it a little bit.
But a lot of people assume a storytelling.
Oh No,
I'm just,
I'm just not one of those people.
So tough for me.
No,
I,
that's exactly why I write these books.
I mean,
you can learn this just like you can learn any art.
Um,
but you can't just wing it.
You can't just say,
oh,
I'm just,
today,
I'm going to be a good storyteller.
I'm just,
I'm just going to practice more.
What does the same practice,
you can't just practice playing the piano and I assume you're gonna get good.
You need to learn from somebody who knows what they're doing.
Right?
So read a book,
take a left,
take a class,
whatever.
And that's the whole purpose of this.
This is a learnable skill and you should learn it.
So to give us a preview of some of the techniques you teach in here,
um,
what are some of the ways you can learn to be a good storyteller?
Yeah,
couple of frameworks.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so first of all,
the structure of a story matters,
right?
Um,
and,
and all stories have some kind of a structure,
but,
and if you know what that is,
you can,
you can craft a better story and there are lots of different story structures
you can use.
Um,
but,
uh,
the kind of stories that you tell at work that you should be telling at work,
um,
either for leadership purposes or sales purposes,
uh,
are short there.
So I found that the average sale story is two minutes long.
The average leadership story is four minutes long.
Okay.
I didn't say 10 or 15 or 20.
Right?
And so when people are telling 10 15,
20 minute stories around the office,
most people are yawning and rolling their eyes and checking their watch,
right?
And looking for an exit strategy,
So these are short to the point stories.
Um,
so you don't have time for a 17 step story structure,
right?
You need a short one.
So what I advocate in the book is just,
it's four steps.
It's context,
challenge,
conflict and resolution,
right?
So you introduce your main character.
There are already into the very next part is what happened or what was the
problem that they ran into or the opportunity that they ran into,
what did they do about it?
And then how did it turn out in the end?
That's essentially,
in fact there,
there are eight questions that,
that I say your story needs to answer these eight questions in this order,
right?
And it starts with why should I listen to the story?
Right?
Cause if you don't answer that question,
they might not.
I mean they could either mentally or emotionally or physically checkout.
But then you get into the,
you know,
where and when did it happen?
Who's the main character,
what did they want,
what was that problem they ran into?
What did they do about it?
How did it turn out in the end?
You know,
in the last couple of questions after the story is technically done is what did
you learn from it and what do you think I should do now?
And if you can answer those eight questions in that order,
you've got a pretty decent story on your hand.
Now.
I think there are a lot of things you can add to that to make,
take a good story and make it a great story like emotion that you mentioned.
Uh,
the element of surprise is a really important one to even in business stories
and leadership stories and um,
sales stories.
Um,
adding a dialogue really makes it feel like a story instead of,
you know,
somebody reading the tax manual to you.
And so there and,
and,
and some level of details.
But not too much.
Uh,
I mean,
you,
uh,
if,
if I were to tell,
start at a story with you by saying,
well,
it was a warm September morning,
right in the leaves were just turning color in the fall and that like already
you're like,
are you serious?
Right?
I mean,
yeah,
I mean that's,
that's like a 19th century romance novel,
right?
And which is appropriate if you're reading in 19th century romance not,
but if somebody is telling the story around the office that just,
that's not an appropriate level of detail.
That's a way too much detail and the wrong detail,
like that's irrelevant to what's going on.
So,
so those are the kinds of things that you want the right kind of the hill in
dialogue and emotion and surprise.
So you combine all those kinds of things and there's a chapter essentially on
each of those in the book to walk you through what the appropriate amount of
that stuff is.
I remember in the book you said there's a difference between a journalistic
story,
like a headline in a newspaper with the inverted pyramid and a business story.
Can you tell us a little bit about that difference?
Yeah,
good question.
Yeah.
So that's one of those,
uh,
story structures that does not work because it's really not a story structure.
It's an article structure.
Yeah.
So journalists are often taught to start with the lead,
which is,
you know,
uh,
four people killed in roadside bomb,
you know,
and wherever,
and then all the details follow.
Right.
Um,
but in story telling,
you don't do that.
You know,
you don't start out your story with,
uh,
and Romeo and Juliet died.
Now let me tell you their story.
You've ruined,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
the stories,
stories are not newspaper articles.
I mean,
they're very different.
And then people call a newspaper article,
newspaper stories sometimes,
but they're there.
Again,
I think that that creates some confusion.
So newspaper articles and,
and really business memos or pattern of the same as newspaper articles with the
inverted pyramid.
I mean,
if you're going to write a memo around the office or an email,
you probably do,
and you probably should start out,
I recommend we do this and here are my reasons why.
Here's the research I did and here are my conclusions and which all serves to
promote and justify the recommendation you made at the very top.
Right.
That's normal.
But that's not a story.
That's a memo.
That's an email.
That's a recommendation.
A story is very different.
The story starts out context,
action,
result,
surprise ending is at the end,
the lesson that you learned is that the very end,
right?
And you can use a story within the context of one of those memos or a speech or
a presentation,
but you would never start a story with and Luke Skywalker,
you know,
as the son of Darth Vader handled,
let me tell you what happened to them.
Oh,
you again,
you've ruined the whole story.
So different stories.
Okay.
So for someone that's not used to telling stories in a sales meeting,
how do you launch into that?
Do you say,
I'd like to tell you a story or what's the best approach?
Yeah,
I'm glad you asked that yet.
Never do that.
And that's about it.
Like the worst thing you can do is,
all right boys and girls gather around storytime right?
I mean that's if,
if you're,
if you're selling to a bunch of kindergartners,
yes you can do that,
but probably you're selling to grownups and grownups don't want to or need to be
told that they're going to be told a story.
In fact,
a lot of people have a negative visceral reaction to hearing that writing an in
fact,
if,
uh,
if we had started this meeting with you saying,
okay,
well let's go and start this meeting.
And I thought I'd kick it off by telling you a story.
I mean,
immediately your audience is probably,
their eyes are starting to roll in the back of their heads already,
right?
I mean like,
because what they're imagining is you telling some long,
boring 15 minute irrelevant story,
you know,
so what you,
the way to start out is with what I call the hook and there's a whole chapter of
the book just on how to,
how to craft that Hook.
But it's literally only a half a sentence or maybe a sentence or two.
Um,
and,
and so it's more like something like,
um,
you know,
that's a really tough problem.
Let me tell you what I did last year when I ran into that problem.
And now you're telling a story or,
God,
that's a tough question.
Uh,
you know,
I think the best example of that I've ever seen was,
and now you're telling a story now.
So it's literally a one sentence lead in that tells the audience,
I'm going to tell you something that's very important to you.
So here and here and here goes as opposed to being told,
I'm going to tell you a story.
Just that word story is really never going to serve you well when you're telling
a story.
Oh yeah.
Great Advice.
There's a particular story in this book that you share about a sales team that
brings in their vice president and you know,
he's damages the relationship to some extent.
Could you share a little bit about that story with us or man retell it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the,
what happened was this,
um,
a company had,
was calling our retail a retailer and the manufacturer had raised their prices
and it just,
it upset the retailer.
They were upset about the,
the increase in prices.
And they wanted to essentially yell at somebody,
um,
from headquarters,
somebody important,
right?
So bring out one of your executives so that we can chew them out and tell them
how unhappy you are with this price increase.
And so this guy,
um,
who's fictitious name and the stories,
Bob Jacobson,
uh,
it gets called out from headquarters to go on this,
to this sales meeting and uh,
he's there.
And then in the meetings going pretty well.
There was some yelling and screaming and there was a lot of tension in the room,
uh,
but when it was all over and did nicely and nobody,
you know,
they didn't get kicked out of distribution and the relationship wasn't spoiled
and everything,
it actually ended up pretty well.
Um,
Bob pulls out his business card and hands it to the buyer,
the client and said,
look,
a,
this relationship was really important to me.
Um,
so here's my card.
Feel free to call me directly anytime.
You know,
sometimes things can get lost in translation.
I just want you to know that,
you know,
I'm here for you whenever.
And then the other meeting's over and everybody went home and he of course
thought he had done this great job and had saved the relationship with this
client at the end is retailer.
Um,
and they,
they're debriefing with the rest.
He's debriefing with the rest of the sales team after it's over.
And he said,
well,
that went pretty well,
didn't it?
And they looked at him like he was from Mars.
Like,
well,
yeah,
Bob.
It was going great until the end where you handed Your Business Card to the
buyer and basically told them that we were a bunch of idiots that couldn't even
pass along a message to headquarters without something getting lost in
translation.
Like you basically cost us,
you know,
that that 10 seconds costs us six months of,
of equity that we've had to develop with that client.
They will take us another six months started back.
Right.
And so just he thought he had done this wonderful job,
but he'd really totally thrown the whole team under the bus and,
and learned a valuable lesson and ended up losing his job over it.
Right.
But he won't make that mistake again.
So tell us in your,
the trainings,
you do keynote presentations,
you do trainings,
what type of work do you do with the clients you work with?
Yeah,
yeah.
So,
so teaching them how to use storytelling betters,
I guess the obvious solution.
And by the way,
that,
like that story that I just told you,
that story type number 25,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's one of the types of stories that you would tell not to a buyer and not to
yourself,
but to your peers.
It's a type of story you would tell about that sales call you went on that went,
that went great or went awfully so that they can learn from it.
So that's just one of the types of storytelling.
Yeah.
So,
so typically,
I mean,
I'll,
I'll do keynotes that could be in front of him,
you know,
a large audience of a thousand people or something.
But more typically I am with a small group of 15 to 30,
35 people,
uh,
for a whole day.
My teaching them the real nuts and bolts of how do you use storytelling?
How do you craft stories for leadership purposes or sales purposes?
And we walked through all of the,
the components of the story structure and then the use of emotion and how to use
the element of surprise and,
uh,
the right dialogue in details and basically of modules and a,
and a case study I think that I go through on each of these.
Um,
and they'll often bring in their own stories as well and we'll,
we'll work on those so they can see how they take what was an okay story or
maybe not even a story at all.
And we turn it into a great story by the end of the day.
Okay.
That sounds great.
Um,
do you see storytelling as becoming a more,
a serious business topic,
maybe being taught in business schools in the future or what is the situation
with that now?
Yeah,
I hope so.
In fact,
I think it is.
So like when I was in business school 20 some odd years ago,
it was definitely not.
But I've heard that there are a few,
a handful of schools that are beginning to teach this.
I,
and in fact,
I know that,
uh,
that one of my books is being used as a,
a taxed in several classes.
Maybe not the only tax,
but so I know that's beginning to happen.
So it's definitely a,
um,
a more seriously sought after skill now.
Yeah.
Great.
Hm.
I think we're going to see if there's any questions from the group here.
Yeah,
yeah.
Does anyone here have any questions for Paul about storytelling business stories
though?
Well,
you mentioned,
at least from your intro that you had these research teams for quite a number of
years,
Huh?
Yup.
Putting it out that and those custom analysis,
I imagine those are somewhat long stories now.
There's not just necessarily one point to draw that.
So can you tell us a little bit about how you saw that transition to this short
two to four minutes detailed role that you've lived in?
Yeah,
so,
so the question is about,
uh,
research and analysis.
I had to turn that into,
into stories and so I,
if I could clarify a little bit.
Um,
so I'm not suggesting that you take an entire analysis and turn it into one,
two minute story.
I'm suggesting that out of you may have a one hour presentation to present the
results of your analysis.
We,
you should use all of that that you need.
Um,
and you should two or three times within that hour,
you should use a two or three minute story.
Um,
and so I'm not talking about,
uh,
replacing an entire hour of a,
of analysis and presentation with,
with one story,
but,
but illustrating it throughout with some of those.
Um,
and I think if I could answer another question,
it's probably buried in there.
Is,
is how do you tell a story with data?
Cause I,
I,
it's probably a lot of the world that you traffic in is our numbers and I think
you can tell stories with data as well.
So for example,
um,
and at one point I had done an analysis of 40 years worth of sales and profit
data,
uh,
in one of the P and g businesses that I was working on.
And I found a very interesting correlation in that the first 20 some odd years
of the state of there was a very strong correlation between sales and profit,
but for the next 20 years there was no relationship whatsoever,
no zero correlation between sales and profit,
which led me to some very interesting conclusions and led me to a very specific
recommendation that I wanted to make.
And normally what I was taught to do is go in and tell them,
I recommend that we do this and here's my reason why and here's the data that
supports it.
By the way,
here's the correlation chart that shows you know the data,
but that's not what I did.
I went,
I used a a story.
Essentially I use the data as a story.
I showed them the data,
showed it on the first 20 years of correlation and then I showed them a second
years and it was very clear that the relationship changed.
And then I just asked them,
what do you think happened around 1983 that forever changed the relationship
between sales and profits in this industry?
And I let them struggle with that question and they started throwing out
answers.
Well as that and when this happened or this happened or this happened,
it was like good at answer but no good answer but no good Amster but no,
somebody got it.
The same answer that I came up and I said,
yeah,
that's it.
And then as soon as that happened,
it was like,
it was like magic.
Everybody in the room just went,
oh.
And right after that,
all of my conclusions started coming out of their mouths.
And right after that my recommendations started coming out of their mouths.
Like I literally never got to my recommendation slide and it was the best
recommendation,
the most quickly adhered to and agreed to recommendation that I ever didn't make
at PNG.
Right?
Because take walking them through that as a story,
like my,
and I call that now my,
uh,
a discovery journey story where you walk the audience through the analysis that
you did in the order that you did it up to the point that you had your big Aha
moment,
but then stop and let them have the Aha moment because then it's their idea and
you know that people are more passionate about pursuing their idea than they are
about your idea.
Right?
So using a discovery journey story with data that way turns your idea into their
idea.
So what was the reason?
Well,
uh,
the reason was because the market had matured,
so it was,
uh,
the,
the business was a disposable diapers like pampers and loves.
And when it was invented,
of course it was replacing cloth diapers and it took about 20 years for people
to stop using cloth diapers and pretty much all diapering households adopted
disposable diapers.
So once that 20 years had expired and nobody was using cloth diapers anymore,
the market stopped growing and flatten down.
Gotcha.
That point was that pivotal moment that strategy's trains change,
right?
The,
the strategic,
uh,
the strategies that we'll be successful in a developing market are very
different than in a mature market.
And now we just had noticed that.
And so that,
that's what made the difference.
But I waited for somebody to figure that out and it didn't take long,
two or three minutes,
but it was,
that was such a well invested two or three minutes as opposed to me just giving
them the answer because like I said,
then it became their idea.
Great.
The question,
yeah.
The minute that your,
your dad wrote you this letter and then you decide you're to make this
transition,
how did you materialize?
So you resigned and then did you just set out to be an author?
Did you want to be a speaker?
How did your hopes PG developed?
Yeah,
so it,
it was a little bit intentional.
I mean,
I,
I knew that I wanted to be a speaker and trainer.
I just,
I,
I enjoyed that and I did a fair amount of that at p and g and I,
I thought it would be great if I could do this full time.
I didn't know that I would enjoy being an author and enjoy riding,
but it turns out I did,
but I only found that out after I tried it.
And so I thought,
well,
how cool is that?
I found two things that I love it.
Yes,
yes.
So the ABS.
Correct.
Oh,
okay.
Well,
but being a writer kind of goes along with that.
I mean,
if I didn't do all this research and write books and nobody would know about me
and I wouldn't have anything interesting to share.
Right.
So it's kind of a strange business model where you,
you go do research and write books and then people hire you a to go teach them
and train them about it.
Because look,
we don't have six weeks to read your book.
I,
we want to know right now.
Right.
So coming in and eight hours teach us all of this.
So yeah,
I knew I wanted to do that.
Um,
but I kind of had to wait and to see if there was some success with the first
book because quite frankly,
like my dad said,
I didn't have the courage to just quit and say,
I'm going to write a book someday.
I kind of a,
I played it a little bit safe.
I'll admit I wrote the book first and then kind of waited to see what happened.
Good.
Well that's all the questions we have for now.
I think we'll wrap it up.
Paul,
thank you so much for telling us about this book.
So at the story and learning about how storytelling and the power it has in
business and in life,
we appreciate you being here with us.
No,
you're welcome.
It's very good to be here.
Thanks.